[Music]
then you better start swimming I'll sink
like a stone for the times they are
a-changin an anthem for change written
more than 50 years ago is relevant now
as it did then times certainly are
changing so how about why older voters
largely made up of disillusioned male
labour supporters were blamed or
credited with swinging this constituency
like so many others favorite breaks off
and here at least views seem pretty much
unchanged and I walked changed we vote I
still think we should come out I think
Theresa May has made an absolute mess I
voted to remain I think we're always
better together however I think many
people voted with their hearts instead
of with their heads nationally though
when asked if there should be another
brexit referendum 53 percent of those
polled said there should be while 36
percent said no despite that 51 percent
of people say that another referendum
would break faith with the British
people with 42 percent saying that they
didn't think that it would if I knew
what was the situation as it is now I
wish I would have watered at the last
vote hotel owner McNamara sue Lee was
undecided a sudden downturn in business
puts him firmly in the romaine campus I
was taking his down we have to lay some
stuff down and then I am very uncertain
I don't know if I'm going to be in
business next year or not to be honest
it's just as bad as daya
if history teaches us anything it is
perhaps that the majority won't be
silenced forever almost 400 years ago
this castle overlooking Wakefield found
itself besieged three times in one year
as England was shaken to its foundations
by a turbulent march towards democracy
[Music]
trouble is here as elsewhere politicians
and voters can't even agree which side
is in the majority Mike McCarthy sky
news Wakefield
you